this is a brine shrimp as it moves
through the water it creates swirling
Eddie's behind it a single shrimp only
moves a tiny amount of water but in a
large group could creatures like these
move enough water to influence the
mixing of an ocean
to find out research has kept groups of
brine shrimp in tall tanks in their lab
then they suspended tiny particles in
the water which they could track to
analyze its flow by shining a light from
the top of the tank they could cause the
swarm to swim up mimicking the natural
migratory behavior of other shrimp like
krill and as they rose something
surprising happened
together the shrimp produced a jet of
water as large as the swarm itself
forcing water down as they swam up a
decade ago scientists didn't think this
kind of aggregation effect was possible
but this research shows that it can
happen and according to the researchers
on a large enough scale to impact the
climate you see brine shrimp are only a
model organism but the researchers think
that this phenomenon might also happen
with critters like krill which live in
climatically sensitive areas like the
southern ocean
water jets on the scale of swarms of
krill which can get large enough to see
from space could have major impacts on
ocean mixing changing the balance of
ocean chemistry nutrient flows and even
the climate now this effect has only
been seen in a lab and predictions about
its impacts are mostly speculation but
if confirmed in field studies it could
represent an entirely new role played by
some of the most abundant animals on the
planet not to mention oceanographers
would have a brand new variable to add
to their models
[Music]